so she already knew that it was a she
knew for 30 plus years what up what
would you do if you were the father no I
would have been like big can you hold
the mitts and then she could put them on
what's wrong with you what
[Music]
maybe some of us have know some of these
situations I've heard of stories like
this before but there's a dude who took
a DNA test and I think the funny part I
guess is that uh he saw it as a good
opportunity because the 23andMe I
believe was doing a half off kind of DNA
kit sale that's why I got mine I don't
know if it's 23 me I'm just gonna take
that out but point is there was a or
ancestry.com or something yeah that were
nearly half off so he thought it was a
great deal so he ended up buying two
kids one for himself and one for his
father and you go and you spin the cup
yeah thinking would be harmless
he found out he was not did the test
mailed off the test and hoped for some
interesting results which is what he got
uh first thing my dad and I did was
compare our ancestry composition and I
noticed it was a bit off to save the
lease he says he is highly British and
Irish most strongly connected to the UK
with a small bit of French and German I
am mostly Scandinavian and black most
strongly connected to Sweden with over a
quarter French in German and some
Italian
so it then dawned on the father and the
son that they were not biologically
related oh [__] leading to the breakdown
of the parents 33-year marriage oh oh so
neither of them knew that not neither of
them knew bro you're probably gonna see
that a lot more starting to happen right
yeah so like because they were European
and [__] they couldn't tell the
difference and then like because if the
baby came out kind of Asian it's like
pretty clear pretty clear pretty clear
yeah so do they have a talk with a mama
and be like who's the real daddy then
said my mom came home and uh the dad
confronted her about it she lost it
admitted she knew that he was some other
man's child all along and would have
tried to stop us had she known we got
the tests wait what does that
I wonder how she would have stopped them
like what do you say to make it not
suspicious or something
registering online
or are you like you know what you would
do when you were a kid in your interim
report or your report card would arrive
in the mail and you'd intercept it maybe
she would have done that and then put a
fake Result One to be like you are
definitely Father and Son
crazy sabotage it yeah I mean like if
they knew his scent he would she would
have went in and
multiple times if that's her go-to if
her go-to is like I would have destroyed
the fingerprinting kit that's how I was
gonna you're gonna fingerprint me versus
then oh you know what let me come out I
[__] up how can we save what has
happened now we've had our son together
I love him you know I love us or
whatever I think that would be different
so she already knew that it was a she
knew for 30 plus years what a [__] what
would you do if you were the [__]
father Yes I would have started dancing
like a tomorrow
I thought you were beating up the kid I
was like why it's not his fault it's his
fault for being someone else's kids too
I would have been like oh I paid all
that money for not even my own son baby
if I found out about taika I'd be like
how did you find someone that looks like
with the same person
oh like that's crazy
that's crazy to somebody when that
happens right in America you could sue
for anything that would probably be a
first of its kind does it happen in
America we're like oh that that wasn't
my kid can you sue the the woman that
would be a good way to like reverse
child support like I paid so much into
this kid and then I don't know and
emotional damages yeah emotional damage
dude I think that's a good cause or is
it especially if she knew yeah is it on
you though because like what if you were
duped yeah but what if it's your job to
check is it how is it your job how are
you gonna check how do you do a
paternity you didn't have the technology
to check out swab them up you'd have to
go on like Jerry Springer or Mori I feel
like they're I feel like they're the
only ones with the tech I feel like
that's misogyny yeah I feel like that's
fair because I'd be like you robbed 33
years of my life thinking that I was
raising my own DNA dude that's crazy
imagine having to deal with those people
because he didn't get the choice
he didn't get to consent and have a
choice to raise another man's son yeah
yeah I was just put up put on him he was
duped and she knew it all along
that's kind of [__] up if the lab just
[__] up
like hey a lot of game accidentally gave
him with Joe one return it and do it
properly what if that happened but then
she actually did cheat but it was his
kid she confirmed
see this is like different from a
situation let's say somebody shows up at
your doorstep be like hey this is your
kid right then it's like it may be on
you to be like let me make sure that's
my kid yeah but if you're already in the
marriage and it was like through like
adultery and you've been [__] already
yeah you're in a in an assumption that
that's your kid you know what I'm saying
so that's like a she's the one stepping
out yeah she admitted it I've never
heard of any situation where you can sue
the the wife that you married
over this like usually just get a
divorce right dude if Tiff if Tiff does
this to me I'm gonna sue her for what I
don't know damages various damages
totally different remember that story in
China where like uh there's this couple
that was married and they had kids but
the kids was like ugly and stuff oh yeah
yeah yeah the husband sued the one
because she got all this Fake Plastic
Surgery to turn her ugly ass into
somebody more beautiful and he assumed
that their children would be beautiful
yeah but they're [__] up that it was
that a true thing that's funny that's
probably a worse situation than this guy
no I think I think that was proven false
yeah it was like a it was like a a
Photoshop yeah or something yeah yeah
but that's so that's the urban legend
let's say it was true what's worse not
having your kid or your it is your kid
but they're ugly as [__] ugly ugly I
think not is way worse not having your
kid really really yeah because it's my
[__] DNA so I could beat it the beat
it up every time I want would you be
stupid little [__] you know because I'm
beating myself up yeah okay but then if
I beat another kid person's kid up I
feel bad then you might go to jail would
you be pissed if uh Tiff lost the dogs
and then just replaced it with other
pugs and didn't tell you for like and
you're like damn the dogs are 20 years
old now
um
yeah how do you know those plugs are the
same poke you had I I don't know would
you be mad at her though or would you be
like I understand yeah what if they were
identically the same personalities if
she was able to find a one-on-one copy
of my dogs and I and I bro they're not
that unique and bring them tomorrow
they would take a lot of searching dude
I think I could find a thousand of them
that look like that no you can't no you
[__] can't dude have you seen my dogs
yeah they're very special they both look
like each other already because they're
brother and sister they're brother and
sister okay but my Leon my little boy
dude he's got he's got a very Leon
Sphinx it's got a very long tongue and I
would love to see you replicate that
because I could spot that out in a
second I feel like all pugs look the
same they can clone animals though yeah
do you think
when they see you
see him like you [__] look the
same maybe when when aliens see Chinese
people
there's a lot of you guys the hard part
with white people is they are already so
different so it's easier to pass like
you don't have two parents that have
like brown hair the kid is blonde that's
true yeah like a redhead pops yeah
that's two blonde parents and then like
the kid is a redhead so it's like or two
brown eyes and the kid has blue eyes
yeah it's like and then you and then you
look up the chain you're like oh yeah
and Sally on this side does have this
trade therefore it's probably okay right
the very the variance if they don't look
like the mom or the dad it's like oh
again it's kind of part of their
genetics versus I think in other
ethnicities if they don't look like if
there's probably something wrong that's
right if I pop out a kid they're like
you Cambodian yeah you'd be a little
worried that's weird so not only are
those parents now divorcing but the test
also showed that this user's real father
was also on the database as well as a
possible half sibling who shared 26.3
percent of their DNA damn well imagine
not only finding out that that's not
your biological father but you also have
a half divined your actual biological
father and a half sibling so your whole
world gets turned upside down whoa
that's interesting that's crazy how many
people use this service too that you
could possibly find the other guy I'm
trying to find some other siblings
what's more important to you guys like
the relationship or the genetics or the
truth the truth yeah the truth but the
relationship I think the relationship
because once the truth comes out is it
more important that this this one mom
and daded you or finding your biological
mom or dad or biological it might be the
context other as to why that was even
the situation was it through like
adultery because then the relationship
is already kind of like oh right you
know what I mean a little bit but like
let's say your your mom
adulterated or whatever right but she
was a really good mom to you the whole
time then is it so and so that's the
relationship yeah but then you're also
if my dad was also a really good dad to
me and then she like was messed up to my
dad yeah then it still changes something
I don't know what it would change but it
would change something oh as the sun as
the sun they're both they're both still
my parents I still love them I would
think my mom's a sleazy [__] but I
would also think that's what I'm saying
you know because I would also thank her
because this if this father was good to
me what my original father could have
been really [__] up biological dad
would be [__] up but what if both your
parents were [__] amazing but turns
out they kidnapped you as a baby oh oh
because that does happen well I would
thank them because I would see my former
family like oh [__] they suck you guys
are lame no I don't know
right I'd be pissed if you kidnap me and
you're like not even Rich it's like
you're [__] up
but they're poor as [__] they kidnap you
from a rich family like why
you're out there [__] picking wheat
and beets and [__] oh they're [__]
dry cleaning I could have been making
beats but I am picking wow
[Music]